president Trump's condemnation of the
Manchester bombing came during his trip
to the Middle East he travelled early
this morning to Bethlehem to meet with
Palestinian Authority President Mahmoud
Abbas the president also visited a
Holocaust Memorial in Jerusalem along
with First Lady Melania Trump he is
about to deliver remarks at the Israel
Museum these are live pictures Margaret
Brennan is traveling with the president
in Jerusalem Margaret morning good
morning well the president was briefed
on the Manchester attack by his national
security adviser this morning and then
spoke by phone with UK prime minister
Theresa May to offer any support and
throughout all of the stops here in the
Middle East President Trump has made
expansion of counterterrorism efforts a
key theme it's so interesting that our
meeting took place on this very horrible
morning of death
standing beside Palestinian leader
Mahmoud Abbas president Trump
acknowledged the Manchester attack I
extend my deepest condolences to those
so terribly injured mr. Trump had
traveled to Palestinian territory to
meet with Abbas in Bethlehem don't look
for the spleen Abbas said that to
achieve peace Israel needs to recognize
the state of Palestine and halt
settlement construction on its territory
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu continues to defy mr. Trump's
appeal to hold back I am committed to
trying to achieve a peace agreement
between the Israelis and the
Palestinians back in Israel the
president visited the yad vashem
memorial and laid a wreath at a site
where ashes from holocaust victims are
buried he spent a solemn moment
yesterday at the western wall the
holiest site in Judaism while daughter
Ivanka and the first lady spent time in
the women's section
the sensitive issue of intelligence
sharing was raised during a Monday
meeting with Netanyahu the president had
been criticized for revealing classified
Israeli intelligence during an oval
office meeting with top Russian
diplomats I never mentioned you had
another story but the president had
never been accused of explicitly naming
Israel just inappropriately divulging
information that it had provided Nora
the White House continues to insist that
the president was unaware that Israel
was the source all right Margaret
Brennan in Jerusalem thank you